- Hey guys, welcome to another episode
of the Wednesday Checkup.
Before we get to the topic
at hand, which is COVID-19,
we have to address the
protest currently going
on, and the murder of George
Floyd at the hands of police.
I wholeheartedly, with every
ounce of my being, denounce
and condemn racism of any kind,
especially to those of the black community
at the hands of police.
Racism isn't just a human rights issue.
It's also a health issue.
Your zip code says more
about how long you'll live
and the quality of life you'll live more
than your cholesterol score.
And that's a huge problem in our nation,
and it needs to be addressed.
Know that I stand in firm support,
in solidarity, with
those who are protesting
these racial injustices.
In fact, I heard a really great speech
the other day by Killer Mike,
and I'm gonna be linking
it to my end card.
Check it out for sure.
at the end of this video.
Speaking of video, I once again have
to point out that I'm disappointed
in our nation's media.
At a time where we need unity,
they're sowing seeds of divisiveness.
They're only highlighting
the protests when they get violent.
They're not showing the
countless individuals
that are out there, they are protecting
themselves by socially distancing,
wearing masks, being
responsible and being peaceful.
There are plenty of these examples,
but they are far and fewer
between on our media channels.
And that's a problem.
We need to be able to trust the media
to tell us the truth so that
we can make better decisions
for ourselves and our families.
To sum up my message, Black lives matter.
(casual inspiring music)
And speaking of Black lives mattering,
something that has given me concern, worry
about black lives is the fact that
so many Black communities are out there
protesting because they have
to at a time of a pandemic
where they're not only putting
their lives on the line
because of police injustice,
but also because of this virus.
And COVID-19 has already dramatically
and drastically affected
communities of color
disproportionately in
comparison to other communities.
So I worry and I hope that the masks,
the social distancing measures,
the hand washing is going to be enough
to protect these communities.
If you choose to go out and protest,
please do your best to do it safely.
And if you have someone living with you,
that's a potentially a
high risk COVID-19 patient,
someone who's over the age of 60,
has an immunocompromised state,
or has several other medical conditions,
do your best to limit your
interaction with that person
to keep them safe as well.
Let's continue this conversation
about COVID-19 because
people are still getting
sick with it.
And at the same time,
we need to begin the reopening
of America because the harms
of staying closed are starting
to creep up and the benefits
are starting to get limited.
Plus I'm sure we all wanna
get outdoors as the weather improves,
but we have to do the
going outside and reopening
of America, strategically and smartly,
so we don't have another outbreak.
So we don't have this giant second
wave where thousands die and the hospital
system potentially breaks.
Those are things we do not want.
So I thought during this video,
I can answer some of your
most common questions
about COVID-19 this summer.
What about pools?
My quick answer to that
is you could absolutely
get COVID-19 while being at a pool.
What you can't have
happen is to get COVID-19
from the actual pool water.
That is if it's properly maintained.
If the pool has proper chlorine
levels, bromine levels,
the CDC has stated that
there cannot be transmission
of COVID-19 from the actual pool water.
But that doesn't mean if Bobby or Sally
is right in front of you
and they're coughing and
sneezing the virus all over
you, that you can't get sick.
You still can.
So all those other rules still apply.
Covering your face when
you're out of the water,
washing your hands frequently,
especially after you
touch ladders, doorknobs,
and all the other public surfaces.
And finally, keeping six
feet away from others
in or out of the water.
What about the beach?
Everyone wants to go to the beach.
And I think the first thing
you have to do is check local
and state restrictions.
Every beach has different rules,
and that's because different areas
are in different stages of this pandemic.
Certain areas have already seen their peak
and are dropping down.
Other areas are hitting all time highs.
So those two beaches
will have different rules
and different implications.
The one thing that works for everybody
is six feet away from others,
no matter if you're swimming or on land,
making sure your face is covered
when you're out of the water.
Please don't get your masks wet,
cause if you do, they become useless
and they actually cause other problems.
And actually a good recommendation
here would be potentially
to bring two masks
with you, or two face coverings.
And finally, remembering to
wash your hands frequently.
As a side note, don't forget your SPF.
I actually received a lot of
questions from my patients
about whether or not the
sun will actually kill
the virus on the beach.
And, there is some sliver of truth
to this, meaning that the virus does live
a shorter period outdoors,
where the sun's UV rays are there,
but it's not a natural disinfectant
to the degree where if someone sneezes,
it automatically gets killed.
It's not that strong.
It just a shorter lifespan,
not a complete elimination.
What about vacations?
Well, first things first,
if you or someone in your
family member that's gonna
be traveling is considered high risk,
over the age of 60,
have an immunocompromised state,
have several medical conditions.
I think travel is an
unnecessary risk at this time.
That being said, you could
have high-risk travel
and low risk travel.
And to me, if I'm gonna make
a recommendation to you as a doctor,
I'm gonna recommend low risk travel.
Try going camping in a
remote area, rent a home
instead of staying in a hotel.
If you're gonna stay in a
hotel, stay on the first floor
so you don't need to be in an elevator
with a group of people,
or maybe potentially
take the stairs if you are
in a hotel on a higher floor.
Remember, the biggest
risks to your health,
it's exposure to lots of people
for a significant period of time.
If you can lower the amount
of people you're running
into, and spend less time with them,
you're gonna decrease the risk
that you're facing with COVID-19.
At the same time, if
you're otherwise healthy
and you're following all
protocols, covering your
face, washing your hands,
keeping six feet away from
others when applicable,
and you get sick with COVID-19,
90 to 95% of people will be okay.
I don't want you to worry about this
where it's going to cause you anxiety.
Remember my motto from the
beginning of this pandemic,
stay alert, not anxious.
What about restaurants?
If you see your local
restaurants beginning to open up,
do not be afraid to call ahead,
or once you get there, to
ask them what they're going
to be doing to keep you
and your family safe.
If they're not comfortable
answering that question,
feel free to move on and go
to another establishment.
Just like restaurants are
required to answer your questions
about food allergies, they should
be comfortable discussing
COVID-19 safety practices.
What about salons?
Well, again, everyone decides what risk
is okay for them.
But I will say, if you're
going for a hair color
versus a haircut, I would
consider the hair color
a riskier procedure.
Not because of its inherent nature
of what they're doing,
but simply because it takes
a longer period of time,
so you're increasing your exposure
to potentially sick individuals.
We don't know who's sick.
Remember there's a lot of people walking
around who look just fine,
have no symptoms and could potentially
be spreading this virus.
What about theme parks?
Well all the regular rules,
six feet, masks, hand sanitizer,
all of that still applies,
but a piece of advice for theme parks
is to avoid crowded areas.
If there's a long line somewhere,
if there's a big group of people,
try and stay away from that area.
Those are the areas where
the virus spreads quickly.
Remember that COVID-19 spreads
two to three times more
rapidly than influenza.
The last question,
and probably the most important questions
that folks have been asking me is,
where will America stand
at the end of summer?
And I think the answer of that
question relies heavily on
you and me.
There's really a level of
personal responsibility here.
If we open America
strategically and smartly,
and continue monitoring
our hospital systems
and follow all the guidelines
that we've been talking
about, six foot rule,
wearing masks, washing
our hands frequently,
we can be in a really
good place this summer
to prepare for the fall flu season.
But if we don't and we do
everything haphazardly,
we could potentially see another spike
that can cost us thousands
of lives unnecessarily.
FYI, I'm going to be donating all
of the AdSense revenue and matching
it to the Southern Poverty Law Center.
So share this video with
your friends and family,
as these COVID-19 tips can potentially
save someone's life.
And definitely check out this educational,
moving, motivational speech
by Killer Mike right here,
click it, and as always,
stay happy and healthy.
(casual inspiring music)